>> Go.
Go, go, go.
Don't fall.
Don't fall off.
Annie, don't fall.
>> This is what girls will
resort to if we ever get rid
of Planned Parenthood.
She died.
No redemption this week, guys.
We'll be right back.
LOL.
That's Annie, and she tried to
get cute in a cruise ship
stairwell, but like every girl,
she's unable to do
anything fun.
If you've ever been inside
a crowded Walmart and said,
"I'd like to spend a solid week
with these people,"
then cruises are for you.
They depart out of Florida,
and things only get
less classy from there.
It's a floating nursing home.
There's nothing more 'merican
than docking a ten-story
food court off the coast
of a starving yet scenic
third-world country.
They're the perfect trip
for lazy white people
who are too stupid or too racist
to learn enough Spanish
to order a margarita.
Does your local Golden Corral
lack breathtaking ocean views?
Try Carnival Cruise Lines.
Did I mention there's
a rock wall?
And what better way
to experience Jamaica's
rich zip-lining culture?
A cruise ship is an enormous
toilet in the middle
of the crystal clear Caribbean.
Do husbands push their wives
overboard, or do women jump
because they married a guy who
considers a cruise a vacation?
When I first laid eyes on Annie,
I said, "Danny, don't fall."
But it was too late.
That's why I gave her
a luxurious one-night,
half-day trip to Hollywood,
where the only cruise
I want to go down on
is Penelope,
in this week's Web Redemption.
That's my time,
you fat [bleep].
Go get some more salt.
Thank you.
Make it a strong one, Carlos.
I had 14 shows today,
and sadly that was the best one.
>> You got a drink ticket?
>> Yes, I got a drink ticket.
Bunch of cheap sons of bitches.
Join me?
>> I'm only 17.
>> ♪ She's only 17 ♪
>> ♪ 17 ♪
>> Attention: we are now
in international waters.
>> Ah, doesn't matter anymore.
>> Maritime law.
>> Maritime law!
>> What's maritime law?
>> It means that legally
I'm allowed to boink you.
I could even murder you
if I wanted.
Which I don't.
Were you an orphan,
or did your mom name you Annie?
>> Actually, my name's Ann.
>> Who calls you Annie?
>> Everyone.
Where you from?
>> South Carolina.
You ever get to that
Myrtle Beach stripper convention
I been hearing so much about?
>> You know, I haven't.
It's on the bucket list, though.
>> You like South Carolina?
>> I do.
>> How do you feel
about the Confederate flag?
>> [laughs]
>> How many cruises
have you been on?
>> I think 16.
>> 16 crui--why?
>> We just like them.
>> Oh, do you go with
your family?
Do you ever get to go alone?
>> No, you have to be 21
to go alone.
>> So you have to have
a guardian?
>> I can have anyone over 21.
>> Anyone over 21's allowed
to take a 17-year-old
to a cruise?
>> Yes.
>> They don't have to be
related to you?
>> I don't think so.
>> Man, maritime law.
>> Maritime law!
>> Love it.
When are you gonna be 18,
speaking of the countdown?
>> The day after Christmas.
>> Oh, what a gift to all of us.
All right, what happened
in that video?
>> Um, I was sliding
down the railing.
It didn't work out.
>> Now, it looked like you died.
>> Right.
>> How painful was it?
>> Well, I landed on the railing
below me.
>> Okay, so that broke
your fall.
>> It broke my fall--and my rib.
>> It broke your rib?
>> Yes.
>> Did you go see
the cruise ship doctor?
>> I did not.
>> There is a cruise ship
doctor.
>> Yes, I think so.
>> That seems sketchy.
You know there's also a morgue
on a lot of cruise ships?
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
In case people die on a cruise
ship, they're not gonna ruin
everybody's fun.
They put them on ice
and keep the party going.
>> [laughs]
>> It's true.
>> Yeah?
>> I mean, I don't know
if it's true.
I mean, it does make sense.
Doesn't it seem like--
I mean, in cruise ships
are a lot of old people.
>> True.
>> So you know people are dying
on cruise ships.
And I can't imagine that they're
turning around, like,
"Back to Fort Lauderdale."
Why did you fall when your
friends clearly told you
not to fall?
By the way, did you hear that
as you were falling?
>> Her annoying voice? Yes.
>> Annie, don't fall.
>> Why'd her voice
sound like that?
>> So...
>> She a trucker?
She smoke?
>> [laughs]
Everyone asked her for
cigarettes the whole week.
>> Have you ever been
on a real vacation?
>> What do you consider
a real vacation?
>> You know, a hotel, land.
>> Yes.
>> All right, tell me the best
story about diarrhea
on a cruise ship.
>> I don't think I have one.
My brother's friend, though,
the last night of a cruise
a few years ago, did, like,
throw up all night in the
bathroom, so me and my friend
had to go sleep in the hallway
'cause it smelled so bad.
So a little maid woke us up
in the morning and was like,
"You can't sleep here."
>> Okay, I don't know what
racist accent that was.
>> But she was--
>> But it was spot-on?
>> Yeah.
>> Understood.
What a fun drink.
Has fish in it.
Did you know your friend was
a perv and into up-skirt videos?
>> That was a surprise
to all of us.
But, I mean, she's always been
overly friendly, but...
>> I'll be--I didn't check.
But you can't, like, pause it
and see a shot?
>> No, I don't think you can,
like, actually, like...
>> Okay, good.
>> See anything.
>> Were you going commando?
>> No, thank God.
>> Thank goodness.
Has anybody ever been murdered
on a cruise ship while you've
been on it?
>> Not that they've let me know.
>> Do they helicopter
people off?
>> We've, like, picked up people
in a little, like,
run-down ship or something.
>> Were you scared that it
was pirates?
>> No.
>> Do they teach you how to work
the hoses to spray
the pirates off?
>> No.
>> No?
>> You get a hose.
You spray them.
They hate to be sprayed
in the face.
They're like cats.
>> Pirates are like cats?
>> Very much so.
Careful. You're drunk.
>> Attention, passengers:
the buffet is down to its last
2,000 pounds of popcorn shrimp.
>> Brace for the shift!
>> Take me to your cabin.
>> They upgraded me to a room
20 floors below sea level.
It's right next to the engine
on the Mexican cartel's
storage deck.
This is the fastest way to go.
I do not do elevators.
>> Annie, don't fall.
Annie, don't fall.
>> Annie, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Annie?
>> Yeah, sorry.
I was just having a flashback.
>> I'll never let you fall.
>> Ah!
>> [laughing]
>> Whee!
I bet you do this
for all the girls.
>> No. Stop talking.
I'm almost finished.
>> I look like a fat
Kate Winslet.
>> Annie!
>> I don't feel so good.
>> Well, sure.
You're a 17-year-old girl who's
been drinking all night long,
which, I'd like to remind
the viewers at home,
is completely legal
in international waters.
>> Maritime law!
Let's get you some fresh air.
There, there.
Let it all out.
That's a big girl.
>> We are no longer
in international waters.
>> Okay.
>> [screams]
>> Annie, don't fall.
Hey.
Annie had a little concussion
and washed ashore,
where she was picked up
by Kurt Russell and forced
to mother his children.
We'll be right back, but first,